[موسيقى]
في جعل من هذا التاريخ حلبه للصراع والشد
والجد الذي جعل من هذا التاريخ بدلا من ان
يكون فعلا مصدر للاثراء والجمال والتلاحم
والترابط هو فعلا هذه الخطابات
الايديولوجيه المتطرفه الجماعات الاصوليه
الجماعات الارهابيه جماعات الاسلام
السياسي التي ارادت فعلا ان تقوم باختطاف
التاريخي ارادت ان تقوم باختطاف التاريخ
الاسلامي لصالحها كيف فعلت ذلك هي قامت
صورت لنا التاريخ الاسلامي انه عباره عن
حاله حرب بين المسلمين والكفار حاله حرب
بين المسلمين والكفار طول الوقت وان هذا
التاريخ هو عباره عن تاريخ عسكري وصراع
ديني وهذا غير صحيح ابدا تاريخ المسلمين
والتاريخ العربي والاسلامي هو ليس صراع
بين المسلمين والكفار
وابرز مثال على ذلك يسقط هذه الشائعه هو
ان حينما تعود الى المدن والعواصم في
تاريخ الحضاره الاسلاميه في الدوله
الامويه والعباسيه ومن بعدهم مثلا بغداد
ودمشق وقرطبه سمرقند وغيرها الغالبيه
العظمى من سكان هذه المدن هم من غير
المسلمين من الطوائف الاخرى من غير
المسلمين
[موسيقى]
هذه الجماعات الجامعات الاسلام السياسي
قامت برسم حاله متخيله للتاريخ حاله
متخيله للتاريخ غير غير موجود يوافق
اهدافهم ورغباته لماذا لماذا صنعوا هذا
الشيء يريد ان يرسموا حاله متخيله للتاريخ
ثم يقول نحن المعبرين عن هذا التاريخ نحن
من نمثل التاريخ الاسلامي بناء على هذه
الصوره المتخيله ما الذي حدث ما هو اثار
ذلك اثار خطيره جدا على الوعي الجمعي
الجمعي في العالم الاسلامي الذي حدث ان
الناس المتلقين الذين تاثروا بهذا الخطاب
الذي يضخ في الخطب والمواعظ والندوات
والاشرطه والى اخره الذي حدث ان الناس
المتاثرين بهذا الامر ظنوا ان هذا هو
التاريخ الاسلامي او قالوا نعم هذا هو
التاريخ صحيح فظنوا ان التاريخ عباره عن
حاله دينيه مثاليه
ولما تاتي لهم وتقول لا يا جماعه الخير
ترى مو بهذا تاريخنا هذا تاريخنا ليس بهذا
الشكل انت تشوه التاريخ الاسلامي فصار
هناك حاله اختطاف حقيقيه لهذا التاريخ
[موسيقى]